[Musique]
bonjour depuis le 16 juin les députés de
la commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 auditionnent
les acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi ancien ministre et
directeur généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui celle très
médiatisée du professeur didier raoult
tu testes vaccin mais surtout hydroxy
chloroquine le directeur de lee a chu de
marseille s'est exprimé durant près de
trois heures
on les écoute tout de suite nous allons
maintenant entendre le professeur didier
rahout directeur de l'institut hospitalo
universitaires en maladies infectieuses
de marseille pour reprendre l'expression
me sera porteur vous êtes l'un des
visages de la crise sanitaire que la
france et le monde a connue je profite
de la grande attention médiatique dont
fait l'objet cette audition pour
rappeler le cadre et l'esprit de nos
travaux la mission de la conférence des
présidents relative à la gestion de la
crise sanitaire s'est vu doter le 3 juin
des pouvoirs d'une commission denquête
pour six mois comme le prévoit la
constitution
comme je l'aï dit à plusieurs reprises
je sais que nous partageons tous ici cet
état d'esprit notre mission n'est et ne
sera ni un tribunal populaire ou
médiatique ni un feuilleton télévisé en
conséquence et il ne nous appartient pas
de nous substituer à l'autorité
judiciaire et de rechercher des
coupables
la justice a d'ailleurs été saisi à
cette fin nous sommes ici attachée à son
indépendance
notre objectif n'est donc pas de juger
mais de comprendre d'établir la
généalogie la chronologie de cette crise
c'est le travail que nous avons
entrepris depuis la semaine dernière en
auditionnant tous les directeurs
généraux de santé depuis 2003 ainsi que
l'actuelle directrice générale de santé
publique france et son prédécesseur
autrement dit il s'agit pour nous
d'identifier les éventuelles
défaillances ou erreur d'évaluer
l'impact des décisions prises par les
pouvoirs publics afin de tirer les
enseignements de cette crise sans
précédent et faire en sorte que notre
pays soit mieux armé pour faire face à
une crise sanitaire
comme je l'aï indiqué au début de nos
travaux comptez sur moi pour placer
l'exigence de vérité et de transparence
au coeur de nos travaux
c'est ce que nos compatriotes attendent
très légitimement de nous je tiens à
saluer la qualité et la sérénité de
toutes les auditions que nous avons
menées jusqu'à présent
monsieur le professeur je vous remercie
de votre présence avant de débuter cette
audition et nous donner la parole pour
un cours propos liminaire je vais vous
demander de prêter serment
en effet conformément à l'article 6 de
l'ordonance du 17 novembre 1958 relative
au fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires les personnes
auditionnées par une commission denquête
doivent prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
au delà de la sacralité attaché au
serment je tiens à rappeler aujourd'hui
qu'en cas d'obstruction de mensonges
dorfhüs de déférer à une convocation des
sanctions pénales peuvent être
appliquées certaines allant jusqu'à 5
ans d'emprisonnement
soixante quinze mille euros damende
monsieur je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et dire je le jure je jure
je vous remercie
je rappelle que cette audition est
public et ça vous l'avez vu elle est
donc diffusé en direct consultable en
vidéo et fera l'objet d'un compte rendu
qui sera publié mais ce professeur sans
plus attendre vous avez la parole
en termes de conflits d'intérêts je veux
signaler que j'ai un lien avec hitachi
pour le développement de microscopie
électronique en microbiologie clinique
et que je suis membre fondateur de 5
start up qui pour l'instant ont pas
rapporté d'argent j'avais déjà fondé
deux tickets qui ont coulé on verra bien
car on a une sur dix qui rend riche on
verra donc les quelques points dont je
voulais vous parler
premièrement pour pour essayer de situer
les choses la mortalité c'est très
compliqué de parler de la mortalité
parce que vous voyez sur le charles de
gaulle yaser romans sont jeunes on les
prend en charge relativement tôt si sur
le diamant creek je crois que tu es son
nom il ya eu 2 % de morts c'est des
sujets plus âgés donc on voit qu'il ya
une variation dans la gravité dans la
sévérité qui dépendent de la population
qui est touché bien sûr donc c'est
difficile de faire des généralités il
faut savoir quelles sont les populations
et la manière dont on les a pris en
charge
globalement si on regarde ce qui s'est
passé en europe
il ya eu un peu moins de deux cent mille
morts maintenant qu'on peut évaluer la
mortalité par tranche d'âge est un
élément qui est important et qui doit
amener à réfléchir sur les stratégies de
prise en charge thérapeutique
il y a dix pour cent des gens en europe
qui sont morts qui avait moins de 65 ans
et dont 90 qui avait plus et 50% qu'il y
avait plus de 40 85 ans d'accord donc
c'est le sait les données qui sont des
données moyennes que l'on a qui
permettent de voir éventuellement
d'évaluer si on fait mieux aussi on fait
moins bien que la moyenne
ça c'est la moyenne il ya une disparité
donc moi je crois beaucoup
je crois beaucoup beaucoup à la aux
données chiffrées brut
je me méfie de tout les ulcères
l'appeler ça les méthodes mathématiques
sont les habits d'hésiter donc je me
méfie beaucoup de la manière dont on
enrobe et on manipule les chiffres mais
à la fin on n'y comprend plus rien
j'aime bien les données brutes
même si bien sûr on va les tempérer les
morts la perte d'espérance de vie de
quelqu'un qui a 85 ans et quelqu'un qui
à 20 ans n'est pas la même
entendue donc il faut pondérer ça mais
moi je tient aux données brutes parce
que finalement c'est les moins
manipulable
donc je pense qu'effectivement il y aura
un effort à a demandé aux uns et aux
autres de transparence totale sur les
sur les sur les sur la mortalité
il ya des différences dont vous voyez
bien que les gens sur lequel les jeux en
se portant dans les régions françaises
sur la mortalité il y en a qui sont
liées à des phénomènes qu'on comprend
mal ce sont des phénomènes écologique
c'est les maladies d'écosystèmes la
raison pour laquelle dans le grand est
et est plus sévère qu'ailleurs
certainement certain nombre de raisons
peut-être les rassemblements religieux
peut-être des conditions on comprend
très mal l'épidémiologie des malades
fixeuse depuis très longtemps tous les
gens qui vous diront que c'est simple
son sont inconscients ou ignorants de
leur ignorance et tous les gens qui vous
feront des modèles projectif sur des
maladies qu'on ne connaît pas encore son
des fous c'est mon idée en tout cas est
en tout cas ils n'ont jamais raison on
n'a pas d'expérience de gens qui prédit
l'évolution d'une maladie qu'on connaît
pas il faudrait être fou pour penser
qu'on peut c'est un peu délirant c'est
une croyance aux mathématiques qui finit
par être de la religion
donc on aura un besoin et vous aurez un
besoin puisque on est proche de la fin
de données très précises pour voir ce
qui se passe et pour répondre aux
questions de pourquoi il ya moins de
morts ici et sur la puce la deuxième
chose en termes de santé publique
il ya une véritable question qui s'est
posée pour moi cette question la santé
publique c'est 70 à 80% de politique et
20 à 30% de sciences et de médecine et
on a eu l'impression un certain nombre
de cas que des décisions politiques que
je crois à purement politique le
confinement le masse dans la rue ces
décisions politiques
il n'y a pas de données scientifiques
qui permettront jamais trouvé ça parce
que c'est des notion d'écosystème qui a
été déchargée sur des scientifiques et
des décisions médicales qui ont été
préemptés par le politique et sur lequel
là je suis vraiment d accord donc je
crois qu'il ya une vraie réflexion à
savoir quelle est la part du politique
quelle est la part du médecin et quelle
est la part de scientifiques le
scientifique doit apporter de la
connaissance supplémentaires et sur une
maladie nouvelle c'est une connaissance
qui ne peut être que progressive il faut
organiser la mise en place et la
progression de la connaissance
les médecins de faire le médecin de
médecins qui est soignée et les
politiques doivent organiser la société
dé la santé publique c'est toujours
difficile parce que la limite entre les
uns et les autres est toujours un peu
complexe sur le plan de la de la deûle à
l'épidémiologie il ya des choses très
particulier à cette maladie qui était
aussi imprévisible c'est que les enfants
sont très peu touché nous on nous qui
avons testé beaucoup et ce qui nous
permet d'avoir en france même une étude
epiq des études épidémiologiques
on a trouvé que lecce enfants de moins
d'un an est pratiquement pas chez moins
de 5 ans extrêmement rarement un peu
plus entre 10 et 15 en est réellement
ça n'est pas des comportements purement
des comportements puisqu'on a eu
l'occasion de faire maintenant une étude
qui est pas encore publié dans la
commune et de la communauté israélite
qui était très touché parce qu'ils
avaient une fête fait la fête de pourim
qui a fait des enfants auxquels il ya
beaucoup de regroupement on a eu
beaucoup de cas hospitalisés à ce moment
là et quand on a regardé la communauté a
été très touchée on était très en
contact avec eux et on a fait des études
dans la communauté et le taux d' attaque
chez les enfants est de l'ordre de 20%
alors que les adultes y de l'ordre de
95%
donc dans les mêmes expositions et a
fait de paris
fête des enfants on les embarras sont
les touches exactement comme quand même
dû peut-être plus donc il ya une non
réceptivité des enfants qui est quelque
chose qui est unique dans toutes les
infections respiratoires virales les
enfants sont les plus touchés et dans
celle là ce sont les moins touchées
on voit s'était pas non plus prévisible
ce que j'avais dit au président a arrêté
sa décision de reprendre pour les écoles
les enfants sont pas peu touchés et
encore moins souvent malades
d'accord il est possible que il est
possible que ce soit il est possible que
ce soit lié à une immunité antérieure du
aux autres coronavirus qui circulent qui
eux sont beaucoup plus fréquents chez
les enfants et qui ont sévi quelques
mois avant
donc il est bien possible y avait des
travaux y compris qu on a déterré un peu
anciens 2013 qui montrait ses réactions
croisées entre les cours d'un violent
ont pour pour l'avenir de cette maladie
bien entendu le comme disait victor hugo
l'avenir est à dieu il n'est pas nous je
me permets juste vous voilà vous
entendez et donc l'avenir est
imprévisible vous souvenez que c'est
napoléon que que victor hugo disait ça
je crois qu'il a raison il faut laisser
à chacun sa part de responsabilités moi
je prédis pas l'avenir je fais pas ça le
deuxième le troisième point dangereux ou
parler rapidement
vous avez bien vu que c'est ça a été un
énorme conflit dont je vous parlerai
plus longuement si vous voulez qui est
celui de la mise en place du traitement
le traitement
les premières données que nous ayons eue
sur le traitement concernant cette
maladie était tirée des études qui
avaient été faites sur le sahara ce qui
montrait c'était manière amusante pas
aussi le président du reich avait
déclaré que le médicament dussart
c'était la chloroquine et puis les
chinois ont testé et ont rapporté la
sensibilité à la chloroquine rnm civière
qui était publié dans sa l'express et
ensuite on dit écoutez puisqu'aucune
potterien va faire la chloroquine
épisode rapporté les résultats
préliminaires et nous on a confirmé ses
résultats au laboratoire comme d'autres
en particulier associé avec avec
l'azithromycine c'est devenu sa a pris
une proportion cette guerre qui est
devenu une espèce de guerre pour contre
avec des mobiles derrière qui sont d'une
grande complexité
c'est rentré dans le contexte de la
vraie guerre civile qui existent
actuellement aux etats-unis entre les
démocrates et les républicains et donc
moi je connais pas je vous le dis voilà
publiquement sous peine d'aller en
prison et 75000 euros du mans je ne
connais pas trop mais je ne connais pas
bolt est donc c'est pas moi qui leur ai
dit d'utiliser la chloroquine donc voilà
aidé mais il s'est trouvé une espèce de
frontières la chloroquine est recommandé
pour une population d'à peu près 4 5
milliards de personnes dans le monde
d'accord c'est difficile de penser que
et il ya une autre partie qui a
considéré et ses 2 2 sur lequel moi y
compris moi personnellement j'ai eu des
tensions comme jamais de ma vie de
journaux qui m'ont demandé si j'ai c'est
pas c'était vrai que j'avais oublié de
déclarer des conflits d'intérêts que
sanofi si l'on retiré mon papier qui
m'ont demandé si c'était vrai que je
n'avais pas eu l'accord de l'asn sur le
premier travail que nous avions
voir les papiers ça n'est jamais arrivé
de ma vie qui est une tension de cette
nature là et vous avez vu qu'elle est
allée croissante pour aller jusqu'à
publier un papier que n'importe qui de
mon niveau considère que c est un faux
dans le land 7 qui devait le lancer
gates et transparent pour quelqu'un de
mon niveau que c'est n'est paraît il
c'est la même équipe avait publié dans
l'ue un gland d'envoyer les les journaux
ont été les deux meilleurs niveaux sont
les cibles les plus choisis bien sûr et
donc cette notoriété en fait des cibles
incroyablement fragile et dans le new
england is avait publié quelque chose
que comme député vous ne pouvez pas
ignorer
il avait dit qu dedans il y avait quoi
je sais pas combien d'hôpitaux français
et que pour toutes les personnes
il avait l'ethnicité et donc ça
l'ethnicité ça n'est pas autorisé par la
loi dans ce pays
donc ça n'est pas possible si ces gens
si c'était vrai mais analyser à nous
n'avons pas ça dans tel ou tel pays car
nous n'avons pas le droit de marquer
dans un dossier médical qu'elle est
l'ethnie six aides qui existent complexe
un nom un peu complexe des gens dans un
dossier médical donc ça n'est pas
possible donc on savait que ces gens que
tu es les menteurs le point
d'interrogation sur lequel jusqu'à quel
point ils sont menteurs moi je pense que
c'est entièrement faux et une des
raisons pour lesquelles je pensais ça
dans le papier de l'en tête c'est que
quand il rapportait le sexe l'âge les
facteurs de risque qui disait qu en
afrique ont fumé autant qu en asie je
vous assure que c'est pas vrai lisez
qu'on était aussi obèses en afrique aux
états unis et c'est pas vrai à 0,4 ou
0,5 point pris et c'est juste pas vrai
donc il suffisait de lire et pas que le
titre
si vous voulez pour se rendre compte que
ce n'est pas vrai donc ça a pris une
ampleur extraordinaire et le lait je
reconnais que le l'ampleur s'est associé
à des mouvements économiques que j'avais
jamais vu non plus un qui sont pour
appeler les choses par leur nom celle de
gilead pour lequel il s'est échangé
pendant cette période plus de plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'actions et qui
sont rythmées par les déclarations ça
marche ou les déclarations que la
chloroquine marche l'accord qui ne
marche pas donc il ya des enjeux qui
sont d'un niveau que je n'ai jamais
connu dans ma carrière
je suis pas un pigeon de l'année donc
j'ai jamais vu ça
donc c'est une question à mon sens chez
que la fed a commencé une enquête
là-dessus je pense qu'on pourra pas
éviter d'aller jusqu'au fond de cette
question qui est une question con c'est
extrêmement compliqué sur le plan de la
déteste et de la maladie l'âge et
j'exprime une chose je ne suis pas
d'accord avec la décision qui a été
prise de ne pas généraliser les tests
dès le début de mars
l'om est sa recommandé de tester tous
les gens qui étaient suspects ou
contacter pour le coc vie de 19 il y
avait les moyens dans ce pays de le
faire la paix sert je sais pas si vous
voulez que je vous explique ce que c'est
que la pcr c'est d'une simplicité de bd
la paix serre c'est la question du micro
souhaite un parti micro lentilles la
trappe la pcr c'est une simplicité de
bébé tout le monde sait faire ça si vous
voulez que je voulais explique je vous
l'expliquais sinon ce que vous la
connaissez suffit de changer les amorces
et donc tout le monde est capable de
faire ça et tout le monde fait de la pcr
nous on faisait 300 milles pcr par an si
vous disent qu'il faut rajouter quelques
milliers honnêtement et quand on a
commencé à faire tourner la machine
la linge et niort en charge de ça chez
moi a fait 1 458 le préparation de pc on
à fournir tout le monde à nice à toulon
et c'est donc à voir ça le vrai problème
c'est l extraction et donc on a acheté
plusieurs machines pour pouvoir
différentes modes d'extraction parce que
c'était rapidement épuisé donc
et pourquoi il fallait faire absolument
la pcr
c'est parce que sinon on était obligé
une déraison explorer 6 la causalité
toujours un peu compliqué mais une des
raisons est qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
dans les problèmes que je soulève un qui
sont des problèmes structurels jeux qui
sont anciens et qui sont structurels de
vos collègues me rappeler que je disais
la même chose en 2012
un des problèmes de fond ici c'est ce
que ce que les gens appellent un centre
national de référence lors il pouvait
pas y avoir de centre national de
référence pour ce qu on a un virus
puisqu'il n'existait pas je vois pas
comment on aurait pu désigner un
ensemble de références pour ça il ya des
gens qui ont dit c'est nous la référence
et il n'y a que nous qui pouvons avoir
le faire moi-même a même dit au début
que je pouvais pas faire des diagnostics
de coronavirus est comme moi donc c'est
les mêmes pcr dressé mêmes trucs on
on les choisit puis voilà donc c'est pas
vrai donc il ya une part d'intoxication
et c'est moi qui ai expliqué excuses au
président pour la première fois et qui
lui ai redit vous savez la pcr c'est
très simple et tout le monde peut faire
et donc c'est pendant tout ce temps on
n'a pas dit la vérité
c'est un examen extrêmement san banal
tout le monde est capable de le faire
ça peut être fait dans les labos privés
nous on a eu on a reçu des colis en a
profité en taille seul en profiter des
vétérinaires qui les en a tous les
réactifs pour vous si vous voulez qu'on
voulait mettre à disposition on vous les
donne nous ont donné on les a fait nous
mêmes les tests nous ont donné les de
quoi les faire donc il y avait de quoi
faire c'est pas des choses très
compliquées et c'était indispensable de
le faire parce qu'on ne connaissait pas
la maladie donc on ne pouvait pas cerner
à partir du moment où le test n'était
pas fait on ne pouvait pas étudier la
maladie et quand tout ce que l'on a
déduit sur la maladie on l'a déduit à
partir de la grippe et c'était pas vrai
par exemple une des grandes erreurs
considérables que l'on connaît
maintenant c'est que l'essoufflement la
disney est un très très mauvais signe de
cette maladie en réalité quand vous
commencez à les mâles dans la grippe
vous commencez à devenir insuffisant
respiratoire vous est essoufflé parce
que vous ne n'avais pas beaucoup
d'oxygène et parce que vous avez
beaucoup de dioxyde de carbone co2 gaz
carbonique et c'est pour ça que vous
commencez à être essoufflée dans cette
maladie avait été décrit par les chinois
ce que nous on a retrouvé mais
extrêmement commune ce qu'on appelle
l'hypoxie heureuse c'est à dire c'est
les gens qui ont une hypoxie avec ses
dires d'une pourcentage d'oxygène qui au
lieu d'être à 90 visite à 100% peuvent
être à 95,92 nous on a eu des gens qui
n'étaient pas essoufflé qui avait 90
d'accord et ça si vous dites écouter ne
venait que quand vous serez essoufflé et
que les gens sont à 90 quand ils
viennent ils valent noréade direct
weemer donc ça n'était pas un signe mais
pour pouvoir le savoir il fallait
étudier les mâles observation c'est
toujours la première étape mais pour
observer il faut faire du diagnostic
la deuxième c'est la raison pour
laquelle il s'était pas essoufflé qu'on
connaît nous depuis peu sap a été décrit
dans la littérature c'est que dans cette
maladie l'hypoxie
n'est pas accompagnée de ce qu'on voit
d'habitude c'est à dire une augmentation
du carnet carbonique mais d'une
diminution du gaz carbonique
or ce qui rend essoufflé c'est
l'augmentation du gaz carbonique et
cette diminution de gaz carbonique
associée à une diminution de l'oxygène
c'était connu que dans une seule maladie
pas dans la grippe s'étaient connus dans
l'embolie pulmonaire est dans cette
maladie on a découvert au fur et à
mesure qu'il y avait plein de petites
embolie pulmonaire
et c'est peut-être la raison pour
laquelle cette peau qui est très
atypique
la deuxième chose c'est que en dépit du
fait qu'il n'y avait pas de signes
pulmonaires mais ça les chinois l'avait
décrit ils font systématiquement des
scanners de l'aude aux pour remplacer le
territoire à ce qu'il faudra faire en
france mais on a un retard d'équipement
très anciens très important je vois bien
corriger eh bien il ya 65 % des gens qui
n'ont pas de signes respiratoires qui
ont des légions au scanner et parmi ces
lésions il y en a 11 % petits ronds des
lésions sévères et qui sont maintenant
des gens chez qui on retrouve des
séquelles en particulier des fibroses
pulmonaires donc c'est cette phase
d'observation dont on s'est privé en se
privant du diagnostic a été un point clé
l'observation de tout c'est ça et tout
était bizarre dans cette maladie mais il
fallait l'étudier y compris pour
comprendre le traitement c'est-à-dire
que la maladie au départ c'est le virus
et puis ça devient une association virus
réponse immunitaire
ensuite c'est essentiellement réponse
immunitaire il ya presque plus de virus
et ensuite c'est même plus une réponse
immunitaire c'est de légionelles ca les
tissus sont détruits et là c'est la
qualité du soin qui compte et c'est la
qualité du soin qu'on mesure voyez il ya
donc quatre étapes et dans ses quatre
étapes l'idée qu'on va donner le même
médicament aux quatre étapes et sa meule
à une fantaisie et sa honte c puis la
grippe parce que pour la grippe le
tamiflu de liliane ne marche que pendant
les deux premiers jours ça marche pas le
dernièrement parce que la réponse
immunitaire dur et c'est presque tout et
maladie infectieuse aiguë qui sont comme
ça donc la question était mal posée de
savoir le raid des leurs m d'ici d'hier
ne pouvait pas marcher sur les formes
graves
c'était pas possible le seul moment où
il pouvait marcher c'est sur le et forme
des buts ce qui a été démontré
mais ils pouvaient pas être prêt ce
qu'il informe de début banal pour une
raison c'est que il ya 8 à 10%
insuffisance rénale par rapport à l'om
d'ici là la fenêtre dans lequel ça peut
fonctionner me paraît extrêmement
extrêmement
le encore une fois il ya une grande une
grande folie sur le hydroxy claudine qui
est en train le flux et le reflux est en
train de venir et puis il ya beaucoup de
travaux dans les nôtres pour faire des
analyses y ait eu que quatre études
randomisées dans trois disques
hydroxyque la routine marche mieux que
le placebo plus que quatre en tout et
donc peu importe le temps fera son tri
là aussi on a des études en sciences
région se disputaient la fin le temps
fait mais globalement il y a eu là
dessus une émotion et je le dis là
encore une fois parce que je sais ce que
je pense je pense que le ministre a été
mal entouré à ce stade là parce qu'il
faut avoir des remparts quand on est
politique il faut avoir des gens qui
soient capables d'analyser les les
articles qu'ils soient capables de dire
écoutez ça c'est raisonnable ça ça n'est
pas de manière à ce qu'on se retrouve
par la situation au milieu du week-end à
faire des déclarations sans que personne
ait vraiment lui et papier et encore une
fois dans les auditions que vous aurez
ou peut-être vous n'aurez pas moi j'ai
été très frappée parce que je le connais
que dominique maraninchi qui était le
prédécesseur du directeur de l'asm est
fait avec le prédécesseur du directeur
de l'ads du président de la haute
autorité de santé une tribune ensemble
en disant qu'ils étaient en désaccord
donc je pense que c'est intéressant
d'avoir leurs visions contradictoires
pour montrer que c'était pas de la
science dont on parlait mais c'était
choix personnel je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir je vous dis pas le cas la
raison vous ferez votre idée je pense
que vous vous imaginez je pense
processeur qu'on va passer à l'échangé
avec les parlementaires qui ont beaucoup
de questions à vous poser si vous voulez
bien avant de passer la parole
rapporteur moi j'avais deux questions à
vous poser 3 vous avez exprimé à
plusieurs reprises et vous venez de le
faire d'une autre manière
un regard critique la réponse qui ont
apporté les pouvoirs publics à cette
crise quelle décision aurait dû être
prise selon vous par exemple vous avez
indiqué des doutes sur le bien-fondé du
confinement total donc j'aimerais avoir
votre retour là dessus deuxièmement
votre position face à la gravité de la
crise et l'évolution de l'épidémie a été
amenée à évoluer
finalement au cours de la crise vous
aussi puisque dans un entretien à bfm le
30 avril vous estimiez très peu probable
l'hypothèse d'une seconde vague
vous êtes revenu sur votre analyse le 19
juin
pour quelles raisons votre appréciation
at elle évolué sur son retour éventuel
d'une épidémie sur quelles données
d'ailleurs on peut considérer ce retour
possible et enfin d'une manière plus
générale quelles leçons
doit-on tirer de cette gestion de crise
le premier point jeu comme je les dis et
je le jeu je le redis les décisions la
décision du confinement comme la
décision des masses dans la rue nemaska
il ne repose pas sur des données
scientifiques établis claire et
démontrable ça sera jamais démontré
d'ailleurs il ya des études qui sortent
maintenant qu'ils y écouter ça marche
mieux quand on confine ça marche mieux
quand on confine pas il ya un point sur
lequel je suis assez convaincu je pense
que les rassemblements sous les dents
les situations telles que celles là sont
déraisonnables
après le confinement à la maison il y à
des phénomènes c'est vraiment et je les
dis deux fois président c'est un domaine
politique qui m'échappe parce que c'est
celui de la gestion de la population de
la crainte de la population
est-ce que c'est plus grave d'être
terrifiée de partir d'avoir les deux
tiers des gens qui partent des villes
est ce que c'est donc c'est une gestion
politique sur lequel je me suis interdit
d'avoir une opinion quant à la deuxième
manche face d'où sort ce fantasme
journalistique mais j'ai jamais dit ça
ce que j'ai dit c'est que j'ai montré
que j'ai pu dire au président que je
pensais qu'on si les choses se passaient
comme elle se passe en général avec les
maladies qui sont en cloche nous
commencé puisqu'on avait un mois
d'avancé puisque ici ont compté les
morts et moi je comptais les positif
donc on voyait qu'on avait passé le
sommet de la courbe et qu'on est en
train de redescendre et qu'on pouvait
voir où est ce que la courbe allait
s'arrêter quel s arrêter en mer permet
donc c'est ce que je lui dis après si on
vient de faire un très gros travail que
j'ai présentée aussi je pense que c'est
de là que vient le malentendu sur le
fait qu'on a mesurée quelle était la
courbe exactement des quatre coronavirus
saisonniers qui est exactement la même
donc il ya quatre autres coronavirus qui
sévissent depuis longtemps qui font 8 à
10 % des infections respiratoires dans
l'année qui sont exactement de la même
manière mais qui sévissent pendant la
saison froide qui commence entre janvier
et mars et qui vont jusqu'à
avril ou mai et donc la courbe est la
même et donc parmi les hypothèses
possibles il ya une hypothèse que cette
maladie devienne une maladie saisonnière
comme les autres coronavirus qu'elle
disparaisse comme le sar ce purement et
simplement à la fin de l'épidémie ou
toute autre hypothèse les deux
hypothèses les plus plausibles et tant
que ce soit que ça disparaisse
complètement ça va dépendre du nombre de
porteurs chroniques ça va dépendre de la
en particulier ce qui entretient les
infections de l'hémisphère nord
c'est leur circulation dans l'hémisphère
sud et que donc j'ai dur expliqué parce
que je pense que ce n'est pas clair
l'hémisphère sud à une inversion des
saisons donc l'hiver c'est maintenant
dans l'hémisphère sud
et comme la nouvelle zélande et à une
latitude qui est la même que la nôtre
sur l'hémisphère sud
et bien si il y à une épidémie de
coronavirus actuellement en nouvelle
zélande qui débute on peut se dire mon
dieu il est bien possible que nous en
ont reprenions et qu'elle devienne
saisonnière l'année prochaine pendant la
saison froide
est-ce que c'est clair donc j'ai pas
parlé ni de rebond n'est jamais prononcé
le mot deuxième vague qui est un mot que
je réserve à ce qu'ils utilisent
mais je ne les jamais utilisé sauf pour
vous répondre alors moi je me suis
appuyée que sur les déclarations que
j'ai lu pas sa vocation que je ne suis
pas au courant
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup madame la
présidente merci monsieur le professeur
de votre présence aujourd'hui devant
notre commission à l'assemblée nationale
vous l'avez dit dans votre propos
liminaire votre action votre
positionnement a suscité une multitude
de réactions passionnelles que l'on n'a
pas l'habitude de voir dans une
situation de crise sanitaire vous êtes
ou haïr ou adulé et avec peu de nuances
entre les deux j'ai même vu ce matin
dans une chaîne info qu' une boutique
marseillaise avait réalisé des bougies à
votre effigie et qu'elle rencontrait un
très grand un très grand succès vous
avez fait l'objet de propos
violent je voudrais avoir votre
sentiment pour mesurer si cette passion
qui quelquefois a pris de façon assez
générale une tournure un peu irrationnel
et est compatible avec la sérénité que
l'on peut attendre de la gestion d'une
crise sanitaire que ce soit en matière
de médecine ou ou 2 ou de recherche
vous êtes venu vers nous aujourd'hui et
je vous renouvelle et réitère notre
gratitude
le président de la république est venu à
vous le 9 avril dernier puisque il a
effectué un déplacement à marseille pour
pour vous écoutez donc vous avez évoqué
à plusieurs reprises dans votre première
intervention des indications que vous
lui avez donné
est-ce que vous pouvez nous indiquer
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous lui avez
dit quels conseils quelle appréciation
sur la stratégie sanitaire qui est
conduite depuis le mois de janvier sur
cette crise et comment il a reçu sans
trahir votre conversation mais elle est
importante pour nous ses conseils je
voudrais également vous vous demandez
pourquoi alors que vous aviez été
désigné le 11 mars je crois par un
décret justement du président de la
république vous avez démissionné du
conseil scientifique qu'elle différend
sur la forme sur le fond vous a opposé
aux membres du conseil scientifique
je laisserai à nos collègues mes
collègues vous vous interrogez sur l'
île vous l'avez largement abordée c'est
au coeur des débats nous le savons
évoqué la question de du traitement que
vous avez
initié au sein de l'institut
universitaire de hospitalo universitaire
de marseille sur l'idh roxy chloroquine
vous vous lavez largement abordée mais
je voudrais m'attarder un peu plus sur
la question des tests parce que je crois
que là pour le coup tout le monde vous
reconnaît et tout le monde reconnaît à
10 h u que vous avez été un pionnier que
vous avez été sans doute au sein de
votre institut celui qui a testé le plus
massivement le plus rapidement le plus
précocément le niçois que je suis dit oh
marseillais que vous n'êtes que nous
avons été amenés à bénéficier de vos
sols de vos services et vous l'avez fait
vous l'avez dit très très largement
comment vous avez fait en sorte que au
début du mois d'avril vous réalisiez
presque un quart des tests dans votre
institut par rapport à tout ce qui a été
réalisé en france
oc puisque le président du conseil
scientifique jean françois delfraissy
que nous avons entendu l'a dit lui même
que s'il y a eu la nécessité du
confinement je cite ces propos c'est
parce que nous manquions cruellement de
tests au début de la crise trois mille
tests par jour alors que l'allemagne en
réalisé 58 comment avez vous pu
mobiliser des moyens matériels humains
comment avez vous pu coordonner cette
action pour faire en sorte que ces
textes ces tests soient réalisés aussi
massivement et je voulais vous
interroger aussi par rapport à ce sujet
des tests sur l'organisation
administrative sur les décisions qui ont
peut-être et j'aimerais connaître votre
position a mené des retards
considérables dans la mise en oeuvre de
ces tests derrière il y as peut-être un
trop grand nombre de structures qui
avait été choisi un écartant les
laboratoires vétérinaires certains
laboratoires publics les laboratoires
privés au début est-ce que c'est cela
qui est la cause la base des retards
et qu'est ce qui devrait être organisée
différemment pour que si demain vous
évoquiez cette probabilité
nous sommes confrontés un nouvelle phase
épidémique pandemic nous soyons en
matière de tests enfin opérationnel je
vous remercie
je remercie je suis ravi de venir mais
comme vous l'avez écrit des gentils pas
expliqué je n'avais pas le choix non
plus mais je le fais volontiers
il faut remonter et je m'excuse c'est un
c'est un malheur de l'âge d'avoir de
l'expérience mais faut que ça serve à
quelque chose c'est bien pire que notre
rencontre le la le le moment où j'ai
pris conscience lucidement que ce pays
n'était plus prêt du tout c'est 2001 en
2001 à fantasmes je vous recommande de
lire mon livre sans faire de publicité
de ça commence comme ça en 2001 on les
aux états unis et aux états unis
seulement on envoie des enveloppes avec
une poudre blanche qui serait la lettre
de l'anthrax il y à quelques morts les
choses s'arrêtent les américains nous le
disent pas mais arrêter ils savent très
vite que c'est un truc endogène c'est à
dire que c'est une souche qui vient
d'une forte des tricks qui a été
militarisé par les américains qui
étaient emportées par l'ingénieur qui
m'est arrivé au moment où dixon a décidé
en 69 d'arrêter les la culture de
l'anthrax comme arme de bioterrorisme
il ya eu une la même folie que vous
trouvez la manne en nous la trouvons à
cette époque là où les gens on a mis
déjà en prison parce qu'ils mettaient
sur une lettre vive ben laden ou parce
que il a émis delà de la farine et c'est
donc là même les plantes présentées
mauvais goût ont amené à mettre en
prison des gens devant la peur des gens
d'accord fermer des écoles jean mettait
un peu de farine dans un coin et
rapidement on a été confrontés nous à
marseille à ça et on s'est rendu compte
que personne ne pouvait le faire quand
on était les seuls à avoir un p 3 à
l'époque l'état avait exigé à tord ou à
raison que ce soit fait par diagnostic
par culture et donc on a fait le tiers
des poutres du pays hanté les sols
arides
en 24 heures d'un test et les autres ont
été rendues parfois avec un mois de
retard
je dis pas que ça avait quelque chose
auquel n'a été positif mais en tout cas
c'est ce que demandaient les
représentants de la population qu'on les
teste et donc on s'est rendu compte à
son art là à paris je peux vous dire il
ya zéro tests ne sont faits les gens qui
étaient censés cultiver la tuberculose a
pitié on on les techniciens ont fait un
droit de retrait en disant écoutez on
veut pas cultiver ça parce que c'est
dangereux quand on n'a pas l'habitude et
que donc ça ça m'a posé la question de
la gestion de crise qui était une fausse
crise mais qui était une crise quand
même qu'en essais crise
je crois donc je veux mettre les choses
en perspective même même si je pense que
des choses qui auraient pu être mieux
géré il y avait déjà dans ce pays un
problème de fond qui est qui gère ça or
le point auquel jean suresnes est donc
la suite que vous connaissez je pense
c'est que quand jean françois mattei et
de l'humidité de la santé que madame et
nury et venise à recherche ils m'ont
demandé une mission je souhaitais depuis
le début qu'elle soit plus généralement
les crises en maladies infectieuses mais
kouchner avait dit matin1 seule chose
importante cette bio terroriste donc
j'ai dû négocier un peu mais finalement
j'arrive pour que je ne fasse pas que le
bioterrorisme et les crises dans
maladies infectieuses et donc ça m'a
amené à la fin conclure écouter
finalement je n'ai pas exprimé comme ça
c'est maintenant que j'ai pris comme ça
finalement vous savez les deux dans
l'histoire de l'humanité s'ils ont
tellement peur des épidémies c'est que
les choses qui ont changé l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est les guerres les
épidémies et donc je pense au point où
j'en suis que c'est un domaine régalien
et que donc nous n'avons pas la capacité
d'avoir un model rhea bien là dessus
c'est ce que je dis maintenant lee a
chuté comme un fort à la vauban et je
proposais je vous assure je proposais
pas sûr que tu es content que jamais à
marseille il faut qu'ils en aient 7 en
france dont un à paris à lyon à lille
pour avoir un endroit dans lequel on
puisse recevoir les malades dans lequel
on puisse faire des milliers de tests
dans lequel on puisse faire de la
recherche et de la veille
épidémiologique on peut pas faire la
veille de tout un pays de 65 millions
d'habitants
à saint maurice je pensais ça et je
pense encore et j'ai écrit ça en 2003
serieslive vous pouvez le dire
donc je n'ai pas changé d'avis et
nous sommes restés par confort ou par
fadik ou bien alors par le rythme
politique qui change trop vite on avait
calculé que la durée d'amis ni de la
santé de ces deux ans et demi si on
prépare les choses avancent ça va si
c'est pas préparé à l'avancé impossible
c'est pas ça et donc si vous voulez
comme son d'espérance de vie comme midi
de la santé est très faible
sa capacité à mettre en place est
d'ailleurs celle de jean françois mattei
a pas été non plus moins que ça mais
dans les recommandations que je lui
faisais j'avais mis et c'était un sujet
de dispute avec son cabinet qu'il
fallait surveiller au jour le jour la
mortalité parce que s'il y avait une
mortalité de quelque chose d'inconnu
on ne le saurait pas c'est l'analyse de
la mortalité n'était jamais fait arrêter
s'était confiée à l'inserm et quand il a
ressorti l'analyse de la mortalité
il a eu la surprise que de voir que
depuis la guerre il y avait eu en
réalité si pic de mortalité 3 de grippe
et 3 de canicule que personne n'avait vu
et qui était dé chaque fois des pics de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes
personne ne surveillait la mortalité est
quelque chose que je connais parce que
dans les maladies infectieuses de
maladies légionnaires et le sida ont été
découverts sur des données comme ça d'
analyse systématique ce qu'on appelle la
surveillance syndromique cia qui ne
passe pas par le diagnostic ce donc pour
trouver les choses inconnues ou ne peut
pas compter sur le diagnostic quand on
les connaît quand on y connaît en
revanche donc depuis cette époque là je
pense ça ça n'a pas été mis en place
mais après je me suis convaincu moi même
j'étais un peu découragé mais je suis
allé j'ai été invité à shanghai et quand
j'ai été à shanghai j'ai eu un choc en
2005 j'ai vu en réponse aux ars
en deux ans il avait fait quelque chose
qui est 10 fois le chu et y est mieux
équipé que que lee a chu et y est mieux
équipé klich 2005
donc ça m'a redonné le goût de delà de
relancer ce projet et ce projet au lieu
de passer comme ce qu'il aurait dû être
un projet régalien est devenu un projet
de recherche tant mieux on fait beaucoup
de recherches qui intègre et la
construction d'un centre de soins et
d'observation et d'un centre de lutte
contre les crises
et donc c'est une vraie donc le la
nécessité de ça c'est quelque chose moi
auquel moi je crois depuis 20 ans
je suis encore plus convaincu qu'avant
mais qui a été difficile à mettre en
place parce que encore une fois ça remet
en cause notre manière d'organiser les
choses
on a eu juste qu'il y à 50 ans un
institut pasteur où il y avait des
malades qui faisait des milliers de
diagnostic qui faisait d'épidémiologique
terrain c'est plus vrai l'institut
pasteur est devenu un institut de
recherche fondamentale dans lequel cette
activité marginale
vous pouvez pas dire que vous allez
gérer une crise avec des gens qui n'ont
pas les malades ni les moyens de faire
10000 20000 30000 pcr par jour
c'est pas possible ça ça peut se faire
que dans les hôpitaux que dans les ch et
l'inserm et partie des chu luu
l'institut pasteur n'y est pas et donc
si vous n'êtes pas une réflexion de fond
d'une part sur mailler le territoire de
centres capables de faire face à une
crise et pas qu'à marseille et sur la
réflexion qu'il y as d'imposer sa et pas
de laisser le jeu parce que nous avons
aussi le jeu des nôtres d'élections dcm
eu des changements de directeurs
d'hôpitaux nous on en change tous les
deux ans est dure comme les visent la
santé madame le directeur
donc on peut pas mettre des plans avec
ça il faut que l'état dit écoutez voilà
dans chaque zone de défense
je dois avoir un centre capables de
m'aider à gérer une crise de maladies
infectieuses y compris si cette crise se
révèle à la fin être une crise factice
ça fait partie d'un domaine je pense
régalien de l'état monsieur plus
d'autres questions je m'emballe sur les
tests comment sur les irritants était
sur les tests c'est la même chose c'est
à dire que je suis très autres bien que
j'en ai un
j'ai un centre national de référence aux
deux mains mais je suis hostile aux
centres nationaux de référence
si les centres nationaux de référence
devienne le le petit monopole ou le
terrain de chasse des gens qui font ça
j'ai déjà eu ça pour ebola j'ai beaucoup
protesté on nous empêchait de faire la
paix cpcr pour ebola en dehors du p4 de
lyon
donc quand on avait un malade il fallait
envoyer le prélèvement
le sérum de marseille à lyon lors des
gens nés il ya une histoire à toulon
comme ça deux malheureux rien paludisme
mettez le malheur d'arriver au mans
tout le monde avait peur des mots là
alors il avait déjà piqué tout d'un coup
il ya quelqu'un qui dit pourquoi pas et
bola il n'avait plus le droit de le
piquer répliqué samedi d'avant donc ils
nous ont envoyés à marseille pour qu'on
le pic mais nous on n'a pas le droit de
tester tout pour le faire il ya des
réactifs qui était commercialisé pour
faire le diagnostic des mollahs mais il
a fallu l'envoyer à lyon pour que ça
fait alors ceux qui ont compris qu'il
fallait pas le faire à la fin c'est les
militaires à paris dans des enduits et
make or l on va le faire chez nous a
déjà d'accord mais donc il faut voir
comment le fait d'avoir un centre de
référence comporte en permanence le
risque ça devient l'homme de l'année si
vous voulez de de dire écoutez voilà
c'est ma maladie c'est moi qui le fais
je veux rien qu'on m'enlève nous au
centre de référence m'excuse de vous de
dire ça ça fait de la peine je n'ai rien
contre lui mais nous on a demandé à
bruno lina nous envoler ressouche tout
de suite pour avoir un témoin positif
vivent plutôt que faire un témoin
auditif artificielle nous a jamais
répondu et c'est une situation de crise
d'accor donc il faut faire attention les
humains sont des humains si vous confiez
si vous voulez la sécurité du pays à des
gens qui considèrent que c'est leur
affaire personnelle je pense que vous ne
voyez pas ce qu'est la nature des
responsabilités que nous essayons
d'avoir collectivement donc ça moi j'ai
fait ça je voulais ça a été fait dans la
douleur je vous assure les achu si vous
lisez son histoire folle à lire et pour
l'ide ça a été fait dans la douleur ça
continue ça a été fait dans la douleur
mais moi je j'estime que il estime
maintenant que j'ai fait mon devoir
on a amené maintenant la preuve de
concept qu' il fallait avoir quelque
chose de cette nature et il fallait en
avoir je crois plusieurs pour pas qu'on
dise écoutez il ya qu'à marseille qu'on
arrive à faire s'écrouler le tordu
mentalité qu'on arrive à avoir des
statistiques sur les données donc je
crois que je voulais qu'on est
c'est l'occasion qui fait le
la possibilité de faire cette
démonstration que l'état doit se saisir
de cette affaire des épidémies mais dès
que vous allez au ministère moi j'ai vu
j'avais rendez vous avec quand j'étais
chargé de mission chez mattei celle haut
fonctionnaire de défense et l'inra 10 et
maintenant c'est nous pasteur disent non
c'est nous même s'il était fermée le
week-end le seul truc qui soit ouvert
jour et nuit qui soit ouvert le week-end
seul chu dans les institutions
il ya des gardes parce qu'il ya des gens
tout le temps donc si vous en voyez ça
pasteur à sept heures du soir qui c'est
qui va le recevoir
donc c'est pas réaliste c'est un autre
temps donc dans cet autre temps ce qui
fonctionne jour et nuit
c est grossière et là vous avez du
personnel et là vous pouvez mobiliser
des gens et là vous pouvez vous
organisez là vous avez des machines et
donc je crois que dans ces gros chu il
faut regrouper les médecins
infectiologues et les microbiologistes
qu'ils sont capables de faire la
biologie moléculaire ça doit former un
ensemble qui répondent d'une manière
unanime et si on fait ça eh bien on est
capables nous a bien sûr beaucoup
d'équipements si je vous invite pour
ceux qui sont pas venus à venir voir les
haches et bien entendu on a un
suréquipement pour faire face aussi bien
à aux défis technologiques
c'est une autre chose qui m'inquiète je
trouve qu'il n'ya plus que les gens
d'extrême orient qui sont qui ont un
niveau scientifique compétitif
moi je ne vois plus en europe et aux
états unis qui est de ce niveau là je
vois qu ils ont un niveau compétitif
technologie qui est impressionnant et
donc je regrette que nous on est là
soient les seuls à faire la course
technologique à ce point avec l'extrême
orient
mais on est parfaitement capable vous
savez pour faire la paix serre si vous
avez un synthétiseur pour faire vos
amorce et que vous réalisez vous-même
les les
la préparation vous savez vous pouvez
faire des pc à tout ce que vous voulez
vous pouvez en faire autant que vous
voulez professeur je me permets juste
rappeler que le rapporteur vous posez la
question des tests de dépistage quelques
qualités votre avis sur la question
être si je madame la présidente si vous
mais autorisée il faut qu'on comprenne
bien ce que vous reprochez à
l'organisation actuelle vous vous êtes
naturellement plonger dans
j'ai par rapport à ceux cnr dont vous
critiquez où on était un peu en cause la
prééminence le rapport diffusion plus
large si j'ai bien compris mais on
voudrait mesurer exactement dans
l'organisation actuelle
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné qu'est ce qui ne va pas on
prend vos pistes de réforme et je
voudrais qu'on apprécie bien
l'organisation actuelle je crois que
c'est capital cette question des tests
vous l'avait dit et on doit aller au
bout de si vous voulez la réflexion qui
a été menée mais je n'imaginais pas que
dans ce domaine le la manière dont ça
s'est organisé est totalement archaïque
solide et qui a des centre national de
référence de diagnostic est une idée qui
est qui qui date de 40 ans je sais pas
actuellement il ya quelque chose qu'on
appelle le multiplexage est un peu
quelqu'un et une affection respiratoire
il ya vingt virus a testé et dont on
teste les vins d'un coup on va pas
demanderont pape a envoyé sa à quatre
endroits en france soit 5 à 6 pour
savoir comment on fait c'est une autre
époque
nous on n'en est même plus là on en est
à faire du séquençage massif dedans et
on sait qu'en ce tour on regarde ce qui
a en a ça dans les deux ou trois heures
nous le premier le premier cas qu'on ait
eu de 5 à 10 soit le premier cas donc
ont eu de positif
si vous voulez en 8 heures on avait le
génome entier d'accord donc on est dans
et ça pouvait être n'importe quelle
viande
donc c'est pas et quant à identifier
ensuite ce virus sur une banque de
l'informatique sur l'essai il n'y a pas
de spécialisation là dessus qu'ils aient
vos idées des centres spécialisés pour
suivre la bibliographie et donc avoir
une bibliographie parfaite c'est très
bien mais pour faire du diagnostic si
oui on est dans une autre époque et donc
on a manqué là une étape 1
donc l'idée qu'il faut avoir nous on est
centre de référence pour l'erika dit
parce que porte la sérologie rica dit
c'est très difficile enfin c'est
dérisoire si vous voulez si la plupart à
part dans les niches
il ya des tests diagnostiques qui
arrivent sur le marché et là je m'excuse
voyez pour revenir sur les cnr qu'en
france on dise écouter les tests qui
sont marqués au marquage qui sont passés
au marquage c'est eux et elles f10 et il
faut que les centres de référence
français d'ici sont bons ça frotte ça
frise le ridicule je sais pas comment ça
pas fait éclater de rire tout le monde
quoi alors en france on sait mieux les
200 nationaux de référence à ils savent
mieux que lavilliers ou le marquage chez
eux ce qu'on doit faire
ça n'a pas de sens et qui plus est c'est
pas vrai parce qu'en fonction du degré
de sensibilité vous avez détecté ou pas
les règles sont croisés donc il ya des
techniques sérologique elles valent ce
qu'elles valent on voit mal comment le
cnr le pasteur dire écoutez sac et
validé par la f10 et par la marque hce
ça marche pas donc cette idée que l'on
peut réinventer les choses en france
dans un petit centre référence c'est pas
vrai je vous donne est un autre exemple
celui là vous paraîtra pas suspect on a
une énorme épidémie il ya plusieurs
vagues d'épidémie d'une infection qui
s'appelle clostridium difficile et qui
m'inquiète beaucoup qui est très
difficile le centre national de
référence est un bon copain à moi j'veux
pas suspect ccc ruimy à nice quand dès
qu'il ya eu dix cas il a dit mais moi je
les fais plus je suis pas capable à nice
avec ce que j'ai de faire la culture de
ça et les génomes de ça je sais pas le
faire
et l'occasion on les a faits nous on a
fait 10 par semaine des génomes deux
clubs c'est les hommes je parle pas des
autres d'accord donc c'est il ya un
effet taillé à l'effet équipements
actuellement qui est la réponse on ne
peut plus avoir s'ils voulaient cette
vision regarder on est à paris et on
distribue comme ça un petit peu on
saupoudre un peu alors comme ça personne
est vexé l'huître attira tout ça comme
virus là déjà ça
et cette proposition elle date pas
d'hier j'avais fait la faille pas c'est
d'ailleurs auprès de didier rous alors
tordu récemment en disant il faut
laisser deux centres comme ça pour vous
faire les maladies émergentes il faut
que les voulait doté financièrement
raisonnablement et on vous fera tout à
la fois parce que les équipements vous
permettent de tout faire à la fois
qu'est ce que c'est ce que les chinois
ont fait un centre ils n'ont pas un
centre pour les nouveaux virus d'un
simple pour les nouveaux corona ils ont
des cendres sont capables de détecter
tout à la fois donc il faut pouvoir voir
de la culture virale il faut pouvoir
avoir deux
de quoi faire des jaloux du séquençage
massif il faut pouvoir avoir de la
microscopie électronique il faut pour je
m'excuserais vu que ça peut être un bon
fils intérêt pour moi voilà donc je je
je pense que cette organisation c'est ce
que j'écrivais ya 20 ans est désuète
je n'ai pas changé d'avis c'est j'espère
que c'est pas par gâtisme mais je crois
que je moi je ne tiens pas du tout à ce
que nous ayons un monopole la recherche
sur les mariages j'ai toujours dit le
contraire il en faut 7 en france
j'en sais rien ou si switch j'en sais
rien mais ça aussi c'est des sondés
décision politique mais il faut que
l'état s'empare de ça et ne laisse pas
faire une auto gestion des maladies
infectieuses dans ce pays avec quelques
tout petits centres nationaux de
référence singe pas et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle ensuite quand une
aubaine de cette nature arrive les gens
disent et moi c'est moi c'est moi c'est
moi et les choses deviennent difficiles
et donc je ne suis pas je les dis en
face à delphi si je ne suis pas d'accord
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire les tests on
pouvait les faire à condition de dire
écoutez on doit les faire et puisqu'on
doit les faire on va les faire comment
on fait d'accord et bien sûr moi
j'aurais été ravi de donner mon opinion
mais c'est jamais bon l'opinion vous
demandez pourquoi je suis pas resté dans
ce conseil scientifique c'est parce que
je considérais que c'était pas un
conseil scientifique et que je ne fais
pas je fais pas de présence pas le temps
et donc les gens qui étaient là n'était
pas je sais ce que c'est un conseil
scientifique moi j'ai un conseil
scientifique pour les accusations qui
fait rêver le monde entier de qualité
c'est que des stars de leur domaine
c'est pas ça c'est un conseil
scientifique pour moi c'était pour de
les conseils scientifiques déterminer
quels étaient les projets scientifiques
ce n'était pas à nous de réfléchir sur
le confinement ou ce truc personne ne
sait répondre à ça donc les discussions
qu'il y avait dans ce conseil
scientifique ne me concernait pas
d'accord moi je veux bien parler de
science je veux bien parler de médecine
donc si on avait abordé ces questions et
quand j'ai appris que les essais avaient
été déterminées par iad aide aux malades
en dehors de tout conseil scientifique
les le projet scientifique lancé par le
ministère de la recherche effet en
dehors de tout combiner scientifique
c'est pas un conseil scientifique je
peux se sait mais c'est pas moi le
premier conseil scientifique que j'ai
dirigé sept en 1989 je m'excuse ça fait
sauf à ça fait longtemps
j'en ai dirigé dans ma fac au ministère
de la recherche en 93
donc je sais ce que c'est par sa conseil
scientifique c'est pas une bande de
types l'habitude de travailler entre eux
et qu'ils discutent au réseau et aux
questions pas en cette occasion pensé
passer assez des données des données des
données qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
et qu'est ce qu'on propose maintenant de
pratique pour faire la science et pour
faire la médecine et c'était pas le cas
je le suis pas fâché j'ai dit je ne veux
pas faire de signe de désapprobation
public
donc je n'ai pas démissionné et j'ai dit
je continuerai à vous informer sur ce
que je ferai et je n'ai jamais cessé de
communiquer
la mise et la santé vous savez avec
l'elysée tout pas mais pas à travers ce
comité qui ne me paraissait pas un
comité ad courage de discuter j'aurais
dû écouter s'ils voulaient vraiment
faire un comité scientifique voilà je
vous donne les dix noms des types qui
connaissent le mieux coronavirus en
france il y avait bien n'avait aucun de
ceux qui connaissaient le gros navires
us donc d'un conseil scientifique
il suffit de regarder il ya des sites
pour ça il s'appelle ex expert skate
vous regardez les 20 premiers français
qui avaient publié sur coronavirus ça
n'avait aucun donc c'est quand même
c'est laisser passer ça la science
après vous regardez donc moi je n'étais
pas d'accord c'était et c'est une vraie
question que j'avais déjà soulevé ces
deux questions que j'avais déjà soulevé
dans mon dans mon rapport aux mini
c'était les conflits d'intérêts vous
pouvez le lire
en 2003 j'avais dit yann il faut faire
attention aux conflits d'intérêts les
conflits d'intérêts représente un
véritable problème et ils vont nous
polluer vous allez depuis le médiator
vous aurez et gardez vous aurez les
autres mais au bout d'un mois en faudra
s'en occuper pour de bon dominique
marananchi quand il était directeur nsm
avec xavier bertrand a mis en place
santé gouv qui était transparent santé
bouffe qui est très bien mais il faut
s'en servir
fall regardez regardez ce qui se passe
et donc quand les gens des conflits
d'intérêts il ne bosse sur la profondeur
des choses qui a eu de conflit
d'intérêts donc ça du conseil
scientifique ou dans la périphérie
regarder tout ça est transparent
peut-être convenant pas forcément pour
nous écouter vous avez c'est pas
compliqué vous avez un site qui est très
bien parce que l'e-santé govou
transparent santé gouv c'est un peu
compliqué parce qu on mélange tout et on
mélangeait les repas etc
mais sinon il ya un site qui regroupe
tout s'appelle euro fort knox avait qu'à
regarder mettez tous les noms euro fort
knox
tout ce que je vous dis c'est tout sur
internet c'est simple comme chou et au
bout d'un moment quand les gens il faut
regarder regard des profondes auxquelles
vous regardez et donc moi je vous ai dit
j'ai un conflit d'intérêts qu'hitachi et
la seule fois où j'ai parlé de
microscopie électronique j'ai rappelé
que j'avais parce que c'est vrai j'en ai
c'est qu'un incontestable ça veut dire
que je n'ai pas le droit de parler de
quelque chose de recommander quelque
chose qui a un lien que le lien soit pro
ou contre
parce que du coup ça revient sur l'idh
roxy coquine elle entendu un accord donc
la question des conflits d'intérêts
c'est une question que j'avais déjà posé
dans ok ya vingt ans je m'excuse tout le
temps passe
tout à fait 18 ans et j'avais posé
l'autre question qui à la sélection des
experts dont on parle comme ça j'avais
dit faites attention vous savez l'expert
qui avait été choisi à l'époque pour
parler du charbon et à l'expert qui
avait été envoyé 10 hervé d'experts
polyvalent cela il est ex électeurs
polyvalent il venait de l'institut
pasteur et des experts j'avais fais moi
ça fait ces publications j'ai l'habitude
de faire ça m'est experts de rien du
tout je dis mais c'est bien ce type
s'est fait choper l'année d'après pour
vouloir passer chez nous à la casse
exceptionnel il avait bidouiller son cv
il avait doublé le nombre de ses
publications mais il y avait un jeune
qui avait regardé sur son ordinateur sur
pubmed des publications et la moitié des
publications que vous avez mis là vous
n'êtes pas dedans d'accord et c'était le
représentant que pasteur nous envoyer à
chaque fois alors pasteur la mineure en
prêt mais ça veut dire que les experts
c'est quelque chose il faut avoir une
analyse neutre et pour ça il faut chez
pain céréales et des institutions dans
ce pays' lolë l'observatoire des
sciences des techniques y sont
parfaitement compétents pour faire ça il
faut leur demander une évaluation de la
qualité des experts et il faut demander
sur transparence trouve effectivement le
fait que ce soit pas de l'auto
déclaration mais que les gens n'aient
vraiment pas de conflit d'intérêt pour
la question dont il parle si si si
quelqu'un qui a travaillé guerre qui a
fait partie du board degrés at parle de
microscopie électronique ça me gêne pas
c'est pas le problème mais si c'est pour
parler du ac/dc vire où ces pourparlers
truc ça me pose un problème et donc je
pense que c'est milton friedman qui dit
ça ou ça il n'y a pas de repas gratuit
n'existe pas mais si vous voulez on va
passer aux questions avec d'abord les
orateurs pour les groupes avec damien
abad pour les républicains
merci beaucoup on aime le présidente ce
professeur ce matin dans une interview
vous avez déclaré que dans ce pays on
adore décapiter les gens est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment qu on essaie de vous
décapité et si oui pourquoi et par qui
j'avais une question de professeurs
d'avoir sur les données de santé
publique france quand on regarde le
nombre de décès par million d'habitants
en france il a été 2 440 soit près de
trente mille personnes
à marseille où vous appliquez donc votre
protocole le nombre de décès par million
d'habitants il a été environ trois fois
inférieur est-ce que donc selon vous si
on avait appliqué et ses gouvernements
avaient appliqué ce protocole partout en
france
est ce que nous aurions pu sauver trois
fois plus de vie c'est à dire dix mille
10 personnes professeurs peron parle lui
de 25 mille personnes est-ce que vous
pouvez là dessus nous nous précise un
somme de choses et dernière question
c'est pour revenir sur les tests on a
bien compris
finalement la difficulté qu'ils avaient
et vous l'avez dit au conseil
scientifique est apparemment vous avez
part été entendus sur notamment le fait
que les tests étaient sur les cendres
d'un sur deux références est ce qu'il ya
eu des blocages volontaire est ce que
considérer qu'à des blocages volontaire
de l'institut pasteur destination de
référence à ce qu'on n'était pas prêts
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui a fait que
finalement on n'a pas eu de politique de
dépistage massif comme vous l'avez fait
vous à marseille notamment dans les
ehpad mais aussi partout sur le
territoire
on a besoin selon de comprendre si vous
voulez vous avez dénoncé ce monopole là
est-ce que vous avez mis sur la da est
ce que vous en avez parler au président
de la république de ce monopole
et est ce que on aurait pu évoluer là
dessus est sûre je crois que propose
d'arrêter je crois qu'on a évolué je
pense que le mieux la santé actuelle a
compris écueil amis il a un objectif est
à mon sens ce qui aurait pu être plus
rapide mais je crois qu'il a compris
qu'il fallait faire énormément de tester
ça arrive maintenant ou c'est
probablement un peu maintenant il ya
trop de cas actuellement mais le débit
est pas le même que ce qu'il était au
moment où on avait la vague et où il
était nécessaire ne serait-ce encore une
fois pour comprendre la maladie il faut
faire le diagnostic
donc on peut pas envoyer désigner les
gens qui vont je vous donne un exemple
qui m'a beaucoup frappé il y a le
chinois qu'avec 80 ans qui venait de la
zone dubai pas de l'uac d'accord qui
s'est présentée à la pitié salpêtrière
il y avait de la fièvre à 80 ans il
revenait de chine il n'a pas été testé
parce que santé publique a aidé il faut
tester que les gens de human qui ont de
la fièvre et de la toux est entré chez
lui et on fait du sept jours après
contaminé sa fille et elle est venue
mourir d'un hôpital dans lequel on lui a
donné du rnd s'est dit d'accord donc
c'est ça c'est toute l'histoire qui
s'est passé quand même de a à z et donc
ça pose une question c'est d'abord il ya
une arrogance qui est de savoir comment
santé les malades sur une maladie qu'on
connaît pas ça c'est pas bien d'accord
et ça ça a été justifiée par le fait
qu'on peut pas faire de test mais on
peut pas faire de test parce que moi au
début on m'interdit atteste encore une
fois donc je j'ai dit écoutez je vous
enverrai les positifs pour que quelqu'un
qui soit meilleur comme on va faire la
pcr qui fasse les petits mois je reçois
des 1000 précisément du monde pour faire
les pc monde entier de la mayo clinic
massachusetts general hospital de
londres monde entier mais je ne pouvais
pas faire en france d'une deux sticks du
coville donc il ya quand même une
réflexion et l'arrêtent mais la
réflexion encore une fois il ya des
choses qui sont des responsabilités
humaines directes et il ya des choses
qui sont structurels je pense que si on
maintient un système de ses systèmes de
petits centres nationaux de référence
vous développerez des personnalités de
niche de blaireau dans leur terrier qui
montrent si on s'en approche
je pense que c'est comme ça c'est les
humains ils sont territoriaux et s'il
considère qu'une maladie et leur
territoire vous êtes perdus voilà je
vous le dis c'est comme ça parce que
c'est l'expérience de l'âge m'excuse
faut bien que ça serve à quelque chose
de vieillir et donc ça en tout cas je
sais ça si vous constituer des
territoires dans la république pour des
problèmes généraux
vous aurez des difficultés considérables
il faut poser une après l'autre et donc
ça rien à voir avec le manque des coûts
vian non c'était la question c'était sur
les nombre de vies sauvées par rapport à
votre protocole que vous avez fait
notamment et je ne peux pas dire y ait
un travail je ne sais pas dire il ya un
travail pour lequel nous on a fait une
opération grossière un qui vient de deux
d'être disponible à paris sur le
simplement le plaquer nil se voulait sur
4500 personnes on a comparé je sais pas
quoi 600 personnes qui ont reçu du
placali les puits
les autres qui n'ont pas reçu il ya une
différence de mortalité de 20 %
maintenant on a calculé que ça faisait
150 personnes c'est ce que je sais les
calculs de leur donner à tout le monde
c'est disponible online suffit de
regarder et parmi les auteurs est
beaucoup critiqué bofa la vie et
malicieuse c'est comme ça donc c'est
bien on verra bien sûr il arrive qu'on
se trompe mais il faut être pondérés
dans ses dents avant d'avoir la
connaissance de ce qui se passe pour le
bon il faut être pondérés dans l'ain
dans les commentaires avant pour pas se
faire rattraper par l'histoire donc en
pratique je ne sais pas il ya des choses
qui ne sont pas il ya deux éléments qui
me paraissent être des éléments
inquiétants dans cette question la
proportion envoyer des gens qui sont
morts qu'en moins de 65 ans à paris sur
les données que j'ai de 17%
je vous rappelle que en europe et de 10%
qui s'est passé quelque chose ici sur la
prise en charge la mortalité dans les
réanimations ici dans ce travail
toujours et de 43% chez nous elle est de
16%
c'est les mêmes malades ils sont tous en
verre donc il ya quelque chose si vous
voulez il y a une à mon sens et c'est
une des vraies il ya de vrais problèmes
pour moi en dehors des phénomènes
structuraux pour lequel c'est pas des
questions d'individus c'est les
questions structure c'est de décider de
ne pas s'acharner sur le soin et donc le
soin est passée au second plan
et on a même vu effectivement des
interdictions du visage de médicaments
qui sont génériques et qui ont été
distribués à des milliards de comprimés
puisque je vous rappelle que l'hydroxyde
chloroquine ça a été publiée par
quelqu'un de la cnam en 2019
il était distribué 36 millions de
comprimés sans ordonnance et d'un coup
on décide que l'on n'a plus le droit du
tout d'utiliser ça donc il ya quelque
chose donc celui qui a aidé à décider de
ça moi je vous assure que lui l'a fait
de faute et après on demand même
l'azithromycine on peut plus donner 5
noeuds au pâtis suspecte qu il attendait
c'est le médicament le plus utilisé au
pâtis aux états unis on ne mangeait pas
ces données en france nées aux états
unis tous les ans il ya une personne sur
huit qui prendre le titre home is in
donc pour transformer ces trucs en
poison violent soufflait il faut avoir
quand même
alors bien sûr si vous utilisez des
doses déraisonnable mais c'est comme le
doliprane sait si vous doublez la dose
maximale ne devrait pas vous mourrez
quand même donc c'est des médicaments
dangereux si on les utilise pas à des
posologies à des à des doses qui sont
normales moi j'utilise ça depuis 25 ans
le placali pour les maladies dont je
suis spécialisé à 600 mg par jour et on
leur donne pendant deux ans donc on fait
des dosages tous les mois c'est mais des
choses qu'on maîtrise donc si vous
voulez d'un coup vous nous dites que
c'est pour ça que quand le papier du
lantus est est sorti lundi à 10 % de
morts vous imaginez bien que je ne peux
pas croire qu'il y ait 10 % de morts
puisque nous on en était déjà à 3000
personnes contre été avec ça et j'avais
mois avant sa tt 3000 personnes avec ça
donc c'était pas possible
600 morts qu'ils soient passées
inaperçues que j'ai pas vu moi je sais
comme il ya deux morts parmi les gens
qui sont passés derrière des murs 36 ans
tous les chefs trois et quatre
c'est pas des données de big data c'est
des vrais données de docteur m'a regardé
on a ressorti le dossier on a fait des
autopsies verbale c'est de comprendre de
quoi il dément d'ailleurs 30% qui était
membre surinfections bactériennes donc
encore une fois ça je crois qu'il y
avait il ya appris ce débat a pris un
tour qui est tout à fait fantasque qui
n'était pas raisonnable et il y avait un
véritable problème c'est que les malades
c'est au docteur de les soigner c'est
pas une dérive qui est que de maintenant
moi j'étais en désaccord déjà n'a pour
dire c'était on aller vacciner les gens
restent à ces médecins généralistes qui
devait le faire on a on a mis des années
avant de remonter sur la vaccination
antigrippale à cause de ça d'ailleurs on
a dit au médecin s'est plu à vous à
faire ça vous savez pas faire c'est nous
qui allons faire l'activation tigre et a
donc l'idée que l'état se saisisse de
tâches qui sont du soin usuelles si vous
voulez à la place des médecins et leur
interdisent de faire certaines choses
qui sont banales je ne suis pas d'accord
et pour le dire d'ailleurs tout à fait
officiellement je suis surpris que
l'ordre des médecins et accepter une
chose pareille moi si j'avais été
président de l'ordre des médecins
ce cas j'aurais démissionné
immédiatement parce que c'est la
responsabilité des médecins de faire
pour le mieux dans leur dans l'état de
leurs connaissances et d'ailleurs quand
pour propos si vous me posez la question
quand nous avons décidé est basé sur nos
résultats de commencer à
utilisez ce à chaque médecin
individuellement dans le soin courant je
m'étais assuré auprès du directeur
général de la santé qui l'avaient bien
compris des choses de même manière que
moi et bien sûr j'ai la trace de ce mail
les médecins doivent faire pour le mieux
pour leurs malades en leur âme et
conscience compte tenu de notre état de
connaissances et de l'aider priver de ça
est quelque chose qui encensent je ne
sais même pas si c'est constitution
d'attelage
je me pose la question c'est vous qui
savez moi j'ai des doutes sur le fait
même que soit constitution merci patrick
mignola pour le modem merci d'un le
présidente sue le professeur dans le
dans le travail de notre commission
nous allons devoir analyser la
difficulté de la décision publique
face à la controverse scientifique et
vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure c'était
très intéressant que au fond c'est
normal en tout cas c'est pas insolite
qui nous soit permis ici de considérer
que assez anormal quand on est en
période de crise parce que les français
ont découvert pendant deux mois sur leur
chaîne de télévision que le des médecins
ou des scientifiques préféré polémiquer
ou s'opposer plutôt que se convaincre et
finalement ressembler à des hommes
politiques dans ce que nous avons moins
bon donc la question est pourquoi j'ai
entendu les conflits de personne j'ai
entendu les conflits d'intérêts mais la
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est comment on est vite ça pour
l'avenir
encore une fois il ya des phénomènes
structurels je pense qu'ils qui est que
vous n'auriez pas de mon point de vue ce
type de problème si le le le vous aviez
des sachants sans conflit d'intérêt qui
discutent entre eux des vrais sachant le
problème c'est que et c'est un problème
qui va plus loin si vous pensez aux
rebelles moi j'ai depuis longtemps et
comme ça ça répondra aussi aussi à votre
question à laquelle pardon je n'ai pas
répondu sur les coupeurs de têtes ça ça
répond à une question le c'est une
question d'hommes s'étaient pas une
question de régime politique en 80 quand
philippe lazare a été nommé président de
l'inserm la première chose qu'il a fait
ses virées les cinq personnes les plus
connus en france dans le domaine de la
médecine
donc c'était en bourget le premier en
fait une greffe de rein au monde c'est
démâté qui a inventé le traitement du
cancer de la vessie par le bcg qu'on
utilise tout le temps d'accord c'était
dos et qui était le seul prix nobel en
exercice et il avait décidé qu'on
pouvait pas être directeur d'une unité
inserm plus de 12 ans et comme il avait
été plus de 12 ans alors qu'ils étaient
en cours de mandat il les a virés
d'accord donc ans tandis que lors de
tests pour ça comme moi j'ai été viré
par les vigiles et dit d'ailleurs
président ça me fait faire partie d'un
club dont je pensais pas que j'avais le
niveau
donc c'est des choses qui arrivent et ça
c'était un mouvement général de sortie
de l'inserm des hôpitaux alors que
l'inserm avait été créé pour faire de la
recherche médicale dans les hôpitaux
toutes les premières unités inserm était
dans les hôpitaux et donc ça a été un
mouvement de sortie de l'inserm des
hôpitaux
donc il ya un vrai problème c'est que
l'inserm est majoritairement en dehors
des hôpitaux
alors qu'est ce qui reste dans les
hôpitaux il reste des cette réflexion
une réflexion très ancienne de la
recherche médicale qui n'est pas dans
les hôpitaux qui n'est pas qu'ils
manquent d'organisation donc le
législateur avait prévu avec la d2 à la
réforme de mairie que vous votez tous
les ans basée sur des critères qui pour
une fois sont des critères objectifs des
biométrique s'appelle les seagulls mais
quand vous votez ça en réalité ça ne va
pas du tout là où vous l'avez voter
parce que
on a oublié de mettre un arrêté sur la
non fongibilité de ce budget donc vous
donner un budget pour faire la recherche
mais en réalité le conseil
d'admistration fait ce qu'il veut il
fait pas de recherche break et une rampe
à 30
il n'a pas de comptes à rendre sur
l'utilisation d'argent que vous avez
voté pour faire des recherches
donc il n'y a pas d'argent pour faire la
recherche sauf de faire la recherche sur
les hôpitaux d'accord est la troisième
source de financement c'est celle sur
laquelle revient c'est celle de
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui est un
budget de financement vous pouvez garder
aussi d'un euro fort knox qui est égal
au volume complet du budget de l'inserm
d'accord et vous avez une agence
spécifique sur le sida et des hépatites
si fait que vous si vous regardez moi
j'ai regardé la la production
scientifique qui se passe en tout et
pour tout chez les gens qui sont
spécialisés en maladies infectieuses
dans 70 à 75% des cas représentent
seulement le sida les hépatites les
antibiotiques et vous avez 25 % pour
tout le reste donc pour trouver des
sachants dans le reste ce domaine là
c'est extrêmement difficile
donc si vous n'avez pas de sachants et
si vous n'avez pas un niveau de
financement autonome de la recherche
dans les hôpitaux comme c'est prévu par
la loi mais comme cela n'est pas
appliqué
vous n'aurez pas la recherche que nous
méritons je me suis exprimé à plusieurs
reprises au dessus c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle d'ailleurs directeur de
l'inserm et m était très hostile c'est
parce que je je dis ce que je pense je
vois pas pour je le dirai pas c'est à
dire que si vous voulez vous ne pouvez
pas peut-être que vous souhaitez samoa
nombre bonjour je crois comme michel
foucault que la vie sociale et à la
guerre civile
donc on se dispute parce que pour faire
avancer les choses donc on peut pas
éviter quand les choses vont mal d'avoir
des conflits entre nous parce qu'elles
vont mal et donc le fait que l'on se
dispute c'est le témoin du fait que les
choses ne vont pas bien et donc si elles
ne vont pas bien c'est effectivement
qu'il y a des problèmes de fond et que
les acteurs qui sont à la hauteur de sa
sont des acteurs moi je
une fois j'ai pensé j'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises je ne veux pas faire le tourner
en permanence autour de ça moi je pense
que de dangers et est ce que ce que
hegel appelle les russes de la raison
c'est à dire que au bout d'un moment la
raison s'exprime par les humains
ils appellent ça les héros je crois pas
être un héros héros fictif
si vous voulez l'utilisent les humains
pour faire émerger le problème un
problème de raison qui n'a pas été
résolu par un accident qui permet de le
mettre à plat encore une fois je ne vous
dis pas que j'ai raison j'ai écrit ça ya
vingt ans je le pense encore donc je moi
je suis stable dont m pignon je n'ai pas
était démentie de mon point de vue par
les faits que j'ai été capable
d'observer mais je les ai peut-être pas
tous et donc le problème n'est pas
résolu et donc le problème reviendra
et donc si vous refaites un groupe en
dire écoutez pour faire la recherche
médicale on va prendre les gens de
l'inserm et puis les gens de pasteur et
puis vont se partager les manières de
réfléchir et c'est eux qui vont gérer
des hôpitaux je vous le dis + 2 ou 3
personnes qui travaillent avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique est
exclusivement je vous le dis vous
retombe à la crise merci boris vallot
merci madame la présidente merci
professeur pour les premiers les
premiers éléments on a un peu de mal à
cerner la place exacte qu'il avoue dans
la gestion de la crise vous avez été
membre éphémère du conseil scientifique
et ce serait intéressant de savoir quels
ont été les léventins votre
participation lors des premiers échanges
je crois vous êtes là jusqu'au jusqu'au
deuxième jusqu'au deuxième avis vous
allez reçu le président emmanuel macron
début des bureaux y avait eu des
conversations avec lui il a d'ailleurs
reconnu que s'agissant des tests vous
aviez étiez visionnaire sur la nécessité
de les massifs y est vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises que vos contacts avec
le président de la république et avec
eux le ministre de la santé avait été
régulier que d'ailleurs s'agissant de la
décision d'ouvrir les écoles peut-être
vous aviez inspiré la décision du
président de la république
j'aimerais savoir précisément en quoi
vous considérez avoir été écouté et a
contrario en quoi vous considérez ne pas
avoir été écouté et je crois que c'est
un peu le sentiment que vous avez
exprimées parfois dans la presse ça
c'est la première question
moi j'ai oublié ma deuxième question
sinon c'est moi je fais c'est le
problème des parlementaires qui pose
trois ou quatre questions dans les gens
pensent que je vous le redis
une après l'autre d'accord c'est le
professeur cissé la présidente mme
autorisé à reprendre la parole après bon
voilà avec un président qui veut pas
bousculer vos rythmes et je préférais il
répondu à l'appel autres comme ça je
pense que j'ai écouté j'ai senti j'ai
pensé peut-être que je me trompe mais si
vous voulez c'est surtout à moi-même que
je rendais compte donc j'essaie d'avoir
les cimes de moi-même de d'être en
accord avec moi-même
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire donc j'ai
pensé que je pouvais être utile dans
cette crise parce que je crois que j'ai
une expérience qui est extrême dans ce
domaine là et j'ai essayé de le faire à
chaque fois comme je pouvais bon il se
trouve que dans ce conseil scientifique
j'ai été un ovni
donc je m'en fous un extraterrestre donc
et pas de compatibilité génétique entre
nous c'était pas possible c'était un
groupe qui se connaissaient entre qui
travaillaient depuis des années ensemble
c'était le groupe reacting inserm et
donc là dedans je suis arrivée là dedans
ce jeu je pense que c'est le président
qui a souhaité que je fasse partie de ce
groupe
donc je suis arrivé second diamant dans
un groupe de gens qui arrivent et ils
travaillent ensemble qui avait 10 des
très précises qui avait déterminé ce
qu'il fallait faire avant que j'arrive
et je n'étais pas d'accord
par exemple encore une fois il y avait
deux molécules dont on pensait qu'elle
pouvait être efficace je pensais que si
on devait faire un effet il fallait
faire l'essai avec l'aide de mon lit
tout ça me paraissait raisonnable
donc j'ai vu que je n'arrivais pas on
nous n'arrivions pas à parler donc je ne
vais pas voulu mais j'ai continué à
penser que je pouvais être utile je
crois que c'est ce qu'a pensé le
président et je pense que d'une certaine
manière c'est ce qu'a pensé aussi le le
ministre faut dire à chaque fois que
nous nous avons trouvé quelque chose
j'en ai toujours informé le ministre
avant d'en parler publiquement toujours
d'accord lui ou son compte ou un de ses
conseillers qui avec qui je j'ai des
rapports tout à fait fonctionnel et
raisonnable donc oui effectivement le le
président macron je pense qu'ils étaient
d'accord avec le fait qu'il fallait
testé massivement
deuxièmement je lui ai montré le début
de la version de la courbe qui nous
permettait de d'évaluer si les choses se
passaient comme on a l'habitude pour les
courbe en cloche de voir que les choses
s'arrêtent atteindrait un niveau
vraiment minimale minimale en mai je lui
ai montré j'étais le premier aussi c'est
un débat jeudi 20h et enfants n'a pas
non plus donc très peu ce que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure
delfraissy a dit oui mais un acquis
d'ici avec etisalat jeudi montre moi
ceux qui disent pas ça et moi j'ai sorti
le papier que je venais de faire sur le
dosage les enfants commis avec moi
qu'elle va garder les enfants et avec
moi qui n'en tennis avait donc c'est le
niveau qu'on avait si vous voulez de
discussion 6 à windham et toi tu dis ça
et l'autre dit ça mais jamais avec les
papiers sur la table jamais avec des
données sur la table et je travaille pas
comme ça je suis pas un homme de réunion
un homme de données content d'être ici
mais c'est pas ma nature
ma nature c'est de travailler sur les
données j'aime créer des données j'aime
avoir les données pour pouvoir réfléchir
et donc s'aimer et je peux même vous
dire j'espère que ça ne fera pas peur
mais je lui ai dit qu'il fallait parce
que il n'y a pas grand monde qui se
souvenaient de cette chose là qu'il
fallait ressusciter la médaille des
epide c'est moi qui ai je pense qu'il va
le faire je pense qu'il fait bien parce
que dans une épidémie à un dévouement
absolument hallucinant il ya des gens
qui se révèle et qu'il faut reconnaître
l'effort qu'ils ont fait que la
république doit le reconnaître et que ce
n'est pas nécessairement par l'ordre du
mérite ou lors de la légion d'honneur
mais par le phénomène
et donc vous voyez qu'il ya plus de
choses dont nous avons parlé qui ont eu
des conséquences et je vous dis moi les
premières données que nous avons eues
sur les séquelles je leur en ai parlé ce
matin encore je peux le temps d'en
parler on trouve des séquelles sur le
vous savez qu'un des signes qui avaient
été négligés et qui d'asymétrie très
très important c'est un perte de
l'odorat en particulier chez les gens de
moins de 50 ans et qui va plutôt avec
des formes pas grave
la perte de l'odorat et du goût enfin le
bout c'est une complexité terrible doha
c'est tout simple et les gens s'en
souviennent très bien et nous quand on
fait maintenant on a fait les sérologies
dans le dos de personnel on les
interrogeait en même temps on a
interrogé trois mille personnes pour
l'odorat le goût l'odorat les gens
peuvent vous dire oui de tel jour à
telle jours je me sentais plus et c'est
une valeur prédictive que l'on appelle
une valeur prédictive de 66 %
c'est-à-dire dans 66% des cas quand vous
allez être positif vous avez moins de 50
ans vous avez une perte de l'odorat donc
c'est très important très très fort
comme test chez ces gens ces études que
nous avons en cours actuellement il à
30% qui n'ont pas récupéré leur droit et
maintenant on est en train de faire un
travail qui online qui a été fait par le
professeur guedj qui nous a présenté sa
mardi quand on regarde par pet scan qui
est une manière d'analyser le cerveau on
voit que le cerveau olfactif le cerveau
qui perçoit les odeurs qui est juste au
dessus des sinus a donc c'est une vraie
proximité et ne fonctionne moins bien
c'est ce qu'on appelle un
hypométabolisme et que ça peut s'étendre
ça en arrière de ça et toucher 1
la concentration est certain
déséquilibre et 2 la mémoire et il y a
des gens qui actuellement se plaignent
d'avoir des troubles de la concentration
des troubles de la mémoire comme
séquelle et c'est toujours comme vous le
savez très très difficile les données
subjectives et peu mesurable de voir si
elles sont affectées ou pas et là on a
des outils et je pouvais dire ça j'ai
téléphoné hier pour le dire mystère la
santé regardez voilà les premières
données qu'on a sur les séquelles
possibles comme j'avais téléphoné pour
dire écoutez voilà dans les scans low
dose on voit maintenant tente pour cent
de fibrose les gens qui sont par terre
en relation donc j'ai tout le temps tout
ce que j'aurais dû transmettre au
conseil scientifique
ça c'est de la science je l' ai transmis
directement et à l'elysée et au
ministère la santé tout le temps et donc
il n'y a rien de nouveau je n'ai annoncé
que je n'ai annoncé avant à mes
autorités de tutelle parce que sa
réponse à notre question
alors si je peux me permettre je vais
poser la question de savoir qu'est ce
qui selon vous n'avez pas été entendu ou
écouter de la part de l'exécutif ou des
autorités de gestion et qui aurait eu
des conséquences défavorables
[Musique]
c'est essayer de le prolonger ce que ce
que vous avez vous allez dire c'est si
on avait écouté il y aurait eu moins de
morts in concreto vous pensez à quoi
si vous voulez je pense que il a été
tenté de faire une vraie évaluation de
l'hydro de cycle rouquine avec l'asie
trop micinn mais la mise en place de sa
a été tardive et que donc le test mais
il n'y a aucune évaluation décès du tout
qui a été mis en place dans son conseil
scientifique c'est une faillite totale
rien du tout rien et il y arrivera
peut-être quelque chose mais quand il y
aura plus de cas donc ça devrait vous
faire réfléchir sur le degré
d'efficacité
si vous voulez de ce type de stratégie
certains vous n'arrivez pas avoir de
résultats du tout c'est en fait au cours
d'une épidémie quand l'épidémie est
finie et les résultats sont même pas
disponibles moi je serais content
d'avoir les résultats de recovery devoir
de les analyser moi même papa pas
d'attendre comble où les analyses à ma
place parce que encore une fois la
manière de les analyser est une manière
de d'approuver s'approprier les
résultats bruts
donc c'est pas la faute sinon c'est pas
organiser les essais dans ce pays g donc
quand même ça c'est factuel encore une
fois est qu'à regarder si vous avez vous
les résultats des conneries je suis
content pour vous moi je les ai pas et
dans un certain nombre de cas je pense
que c'était même pas réalisable s'il ya
des gens qui voulaient inclure des
malades
il n'y avait pas de m6 vire d'accord
j'en avais pas tiré
il n'y a pas de disponible parce qu' il
n'était pas ma nature fait d'accord donc
tout ça cette obsession moi j'ai vu
depuis le début de d'essayer de traiter
gens avec leurs m des civils et quelque
chose qui est de toute manière ne mener
rien parce que même s'ils avaient réussi
à montrer qu'il ya quelque chose de
toute manière on aurait pas de
médicaments maintenant parce qu'on n'a
pas aurait donc il faut se poser la
question de savoir si ça c'était
vraiment purement du jeu boursier est ce
que c'était juste pour faire monter la
valeur de gilead avant la fusion avec
astrazeneca à ce que c'était ça
l'objectif parce que de toute manière
les médicaments les aurait pas vus donc
il y a il ya une question de fond qui à
là question contre laquelle moi je me
bats que je ne comprends pas où je ne
veux pas à comprendre car je veux pas
l'exprimer
merci monsieur lagarde pour les délits
oui merci le président monsieur le
professeur je l'avais prévu parce que je
n'aime pas ce qui est irrationnel ou
excessives comme les médias vous avez
dit vous même que c'est passé très au
delà de la raison j'avais prévu de pas
vous vous interrogez sur sur votre
traitement mais il ya quand même deux
choses qui me viennent à l'esprit où je
ne parviens pas à comprendre c'est
pourquoi est ce que les études que vous
avez faites vous même en même temps vous
soignez évidemment c'est toujours comme
ça qu'on fait des études vous n'avez pas
souhaité les randomisés pour permettre
d'éteindre les contestations de toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont contesté
entre guillemets vos résultats et dans
le sens inverse
est-ce que vous avez une raison l'idée
d'une raison qui fait que quand ou
dénoncé dans le parisien je crois quand
on teste votre traitement en fait on
respecte jamais votre posologie ce qui
est une aberration parce que s'ils
respectent pas la posologie d'un
traitement c'est pas la peine de dire
qu'on a été étudié ces résultats voilà
c'est quand même de questions qui bon
après dans d'autres interventions il ya
quand même
oui bien sûr c'est intéressant mais sur
regarder sur le le site ne croyait pas
du tout qu'on a commencé à m online nos
réflexions et nos cours augmente du
coronavirus on avait commencé bien avant
mais il se trouve que le gros navires us
à amplifier le phénomène et que vous
l'avez vu qu'à ce moment là mais donc on
faisait une fois par semaine je m'excuse
on appelait ça on a doit être
intelligent parce qu'on pensait que les
médias rapportaient une déformation des
de la connaissance que nous avions que
donc on avait besoin d'exprimer nous
mêmes directement sur ce que nous
savions nous croyons savoir faut faut
être prudent et nous avions fait on fait
des jeudis de 10h une thématique dont un
très précisément deux mois avant le
début de l'histoire du coronavirus était
sur la méthode d'accord
quelles sont les méthodes d'analysé
qu'est ce que c'est que l'historique de
la méthode c'est de l'épistémologie vous
pouvez le voir c'est toujours online
s'appelle contre la méthode comment
est-ce que 11
sa compagne mais la méthode ce qui est
une véritable question est encore une
fois le rite delà de la randomisation
des grands essais thérapeutiques
multicentrique d'un phénomène
extrêmement récents dans la science il y
a je pense dans les maladies
infectieuses moins de 5% des traitements
maladies infectieuses actuellement qui
sont basées sur des essais randomisés en
double donc stop c'est peut-être parce
que je suis plus vieux ou parce que je
suis hérétiques au sein seulement le
timon logique que je ne me laisse pas
impressionner par le fait que l'on dise
manens la doxa ça ne m'impressionne pas
donc je pense des effets bien il ya si
on s'y intéresse sur la littérature de
je parle de la vraie science et que l'on
comparé les effets randomisés aux essais
comparatifs historique les essais
randomisés sont plutôt moins performants
que les essais comparatifs historique
donc cessé d'ailleurs tous les gens qui
critiquait sa couse publie maintenant
des essais qui ne sont que purement
comparatif donc si vous voulez c'est
intéressant que ça ne s'applique qu'à
moissac à parce que quand même tous les
essais qui sont publiés ne seront
publiés qu'en février dernier et deux
décès qui ont été publiés par les
parisiens ne sont que des essais qui
sont non randomisé en avance 0 en france
et randomisée d'accord donc c'est juste
pour moi je suis parano visée parce que
je suis agréable je ne suis pas bon je
me trompe pas désagréable d'avant je le
trouve plutôt et par llorente et bassins
privés
un point de vue qui est très subjectif
et deuxièmement la randomisation et 1 un
phénomène qui est un phénomène un espèce
de standard qui est très associé
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui ne me
convainc pas donc ce que nous avons fait
ça à l'essai comparatif
à la différence des autres enfin vraie
fée comparatif puisque on a comparé les
gens de nice avec les gens de marseille
et les gens de nice ne prenait pas avec
un hard comme qui était très clair et
qu'on était les seuls à pouvoir employer
c'est à dire une mesure qui était très
colérique était simple qui était la
persistance ou la non persistance du
virus dans les prélèvements d'accord
donc c'est ça notre premier papier c'est
très simple ces sujets là anglais on
sait j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup
d'études dans ma vie beaucoup de
traitements oui et donc on dit voilà
deux groupes
on regarde chez lesquels le virus
disparaît le premier et il se trouve qu
est venue se greffer un troisième groupe
parce qu'on comparait les drogues
cycloclean ehpad hydroxyde
hockin est venue se greffer un troisième
groupe qui est chez nous les gens qui
étaient plus graves on les traite comme
les infections virales sévère en
rajoutant d'asie trottiner on s'est
rendu compte qu'en rajoutant de l'az et
romy si en même temps on était en train
de la tester au laboratoire en
association et séparément des droits de
ces claudine le nombre de virus diminué
beaucoup plus rapidement donc on avait
une fois qu'on avait ces données on a
fait des tests statistiques sam qui a
montré que c'était différent a publié ce
papier qui va pas poser de problème de
publication et d'un coup ça a déchaîné
influent que je n'imaginais pas et
d'ailleurs encore une fois la question
et si vraiment les gens déjà écouté non
mais il ya un premier papier mais on
doute vraiment scientifiquement refus
met en garde pour pouvoir et donc
pourquoi est-ce que là personne n'a fait
ça
donc là je m'excuse de maintenant il ya
une série de 4500 personnes qui est
passé à paris là qui est de sortir
personne a fait l'effet randomisés
personne que vous voyez et il ya une
chose que je peux même vous dire plus et
les choses qui m'ont sidéré il est sorti
une première étude faite par dd en
france dans lequel il y avait un groupe
sur lequel il y avait hydroxy
chloroquine azithromycine qui a été
publiée dans le british medical journal
dans ce groupe il y avait seize
personnes zéro passe en rien ses romans
et les auteurs ont refusé de faire le
test de base de significativité pour
montrer que c'était différent des autres
groupes et c'était différent
et ils n'ont pas publié d'accord j'en
sais rien mais j'ai une opinion que je
vous dirais pas mais je n'en sais rien
merci non c'est pas fini manager déféré
à la demande du professeur rolf
le prétexte était que les méthodologies
ce 10 ce qui est une fille qui vous fera
comprendre pourquoi on peut pas
s'entendre
les méthodologies se disent qu'ils n'ont
pas le droit d'analyser des choses
qu'ils n'ont pas décidé d'analyser avant
de commencer ce qui est le principe de
l' inverse découverte et donc ils ont
dire ça alors que c'était le traitement
qu'ils étaient le feu à la planète ça on
n'a pas décidé avant de commencer
l'étude de l'analyse et donc on ne la
laisse pas même si c'est significatif
merci voilà c'était donc la première
partie de l'audition du professeur
didier raoult est alors vous l'avez
entendu lors de son propos liminaire il
se présentait lui même comme un anti
système
avant de défendre une nouvelle fois son
trait
abazid roxy chloroquine la suite de
cette audition est à retrouver sur notre
site
lcp point fr